Breana she owns the host this year
oh yes and the theme was heavenly bodies
here you are in your lovely yeah you
stole her the thing I don't know when
you see these pictures of all these
people do these amazing dress I was kind
of think how did you get there because
that's not a car how do you get well
this one was a piece of cake compared to
the yellow situation I did know I had to
call my graph I gotta stretch no more
girls I know okay
the garment yeah be on it I put it in
first and then you stop the car then I
had to put it on in the car but she was
eating when you got in no stop the train
actually had to come out first so that I
was this like how many ppl yeah did
somebody help you say has to be amazing
okay
and I was all choreographed I'm with a
in the car with you yes yes yes I'm
gonna be on to the omelet I can't live
six people we're done
so what what happens with that yeah
where is it now hey you were every
breakfast day I even keep them in
archive or I have to send it back so now
you would think you would think that
people would just see this beautiful
garment on the on the World Wide Web and
you just admire it kind of doesn't grant
a look lovely
but of course they can't they they do
compare it as you said to this they also
they also turned it into a perhaps most
delicious of all against his beef slice
[Applause]
[Music]